my opponents asked me can I start yes
okay here we go this is the guy who
guessed the magic number I put on a
number range you can pick to that magic
number so we have the Sicilian and we
have a lovin let's do something
different i usually play d5 there but to
have a little variety and by variety I
mean what exactly I'm going to be
winning this poem right I take here then
we have e 5 and then the recapture what
if i take efore first let's see let's
see there's Bishop d3 my night runs away
and then there's a capture but these two
are doubled or you know what maybe I say
Bishop d3 I go d5 Bishop takes Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes pawn takes I get
the Queen I have the bishop pair let's
go for that I do open up this diagonal
or some checking issues but nothing that
I should be fearing knight c6 to block
is sufficient so I'm ready to do what
exactly I'm ready to maybe just capture
runaway develop with the knight c6 I'm
not thinking about poncy for I don't
care about making a one move threat and
kicking the bishop back and releasing
pressure on d4 and allowing white today
we have an attack against my king with
two bishops breathing down my neck so c4
I don't even give that a second thought
a second of my time I should say so e
696 I might want to do e 6 because if I
do knight c6 right away to maybe be
kicked butt
it's most pressing right now for white
is what do you do about this pawn right
here I think just capture then do what
next I think with this I'm going to end
up being what I'm going to be up how
many puns no okay one two three four
five seven my opponent has six my first
thought is to play knight c6 and I don't
see a reason not to do that let's get
developed yeah let's definitely get
developed pawn takes Queen takes if
night seat if Knight f3 I if I could
make a move that will defend my
opponents threat out of the opening and
still facilitate my own development I
will be looking at those particular
moves first 'if I've does just that
helps my bishop so Bishop c5 could be
quite annoying as well if C takes D I
capture with the pun although you know
what I don't have to if pawn takes I
could take with my night my initial
thought was that if night my initial
thought was that after see takes the
night takes d 95 could be played but
that's not the case because I would have
available Queen a five and the night is
dead pawn takes Knight takes Knight
takes on e5 he's unprotected my queen
gives check my queen takes the night and
then defends my knight on d4 I could
take this night and then this pond I
don't want my I don't want to go on
castled if I give up my dark square
Bishop I better have control over the
dark squares in the center and I do have
that maybe I could pin the night I have
the bishop pair i want to the X Factor
bishop that I have is the light square
Bishop the unopposed bishop so how can I
put him to good use how could I put
pressure on my opponents position with
my light square Bishop I doubt that
there's a better place to do that
than g4 he is unprotected from that
square but I don't believe he is
tactically vulnerable by being
unprotected on here sometimes you'll see
if that there if there's a light square
Bishop bearing down on f7 there could be
a sacrifice King takes and then a night
moving unleashing in a discovered attack
on my bishop but not the case here since
there's no light square Bishop for white
putting pressure on f7 Bishop c5 is what
I'm looking into next if age three do i
maintain the pin I believe so he's still
tactically vulnerable maybe g4 I play
here he's a fantastic defensive piece
and my opponent is pushing the bishop
away if g4 is played he's breaking the
pin but white is weakening the King
position should he go Kings side and
allowing my bishop to put direct
pressure on this pawn I could capture
now notice how I don't have to recapture
with my king and i believe i do well to
do that keep this pin i do well to
capture now because it benefits me how
exactly benefits me because my opponents
ponds are now split this Bishop can't
move as soon as pond takes the bishop is
tied down to the defense of the night we
should check I don't believe that
there's anything better here and the
last question that I really have for
myself is is it better to Castle
kingside or play King to e7
hmm
oh you know what else might be about
taking the night because if the rook
captures I could give check and then
take the night because of the pin so if
i take the night pond has to capture i
sneak my night over here then that would
be a good home maybe f4 as well bishop
here is a good thought as well King e7
no I with still so many pieces on the
board I'm just going to tuck my king
away I'm not going to go in for that
Bishop takes Knight I think eventually I
want to target this pawn this pond even
though even though these guys are split
he's stopping my night from posting up
on d4 how does my opponent make
improvements it's to be quite careful
actually because Bishop b2 then I could
take the night and then post here
hitting the bishop my rook becomes very
active there night is getting active now
pressure on this pun let me just watch
over it my bishop is also there to
retreat and maybe keep a close eye on a
two to be careful like if night III and
I do bishop here if we have something
like c4 this night is intending to get
to this square just drop this back and
if the Pawn pushes he is gone actually I
was thinking too if c4 to take the night
and then jump into d4 but I'd actually
just be winning some material pawn push
I take out the night and then I went up
on 40 seconds I have a min advantage
Brooke here is also another thought all
right let me take the 9s to run in
Reverse
who's the poorest placed piece for me my
rook could be doing something on the
defiled my night is the other one where
would he like to be further advanced
along this file right here anything
better I like getting him here Bishop is
kind of stuck all right i'm gonna
pinpoint this pond he's stopped too he's
stuck he's stuck because of this i could
get this pond but the rook then comes
over here let me just defend stuff now
this is back on brooke here i can run
away with my bishop actually no I could
have done that sooner my rook was there
to find my night what am I talking about
tricky night checks let's get out of any
of that stuff
and let's put pressure on the night that
is in my position and I think I just
want to take them out but actually
there's no need to even do that I'm
stopping all the squares that you can
maybe be going to let's just get them
out of there I have this square covered
three seconds just March my pawn no time
okay good game UVA fan let's back up and
see if there's something to take away
from this and I'm sure there is right
here just play e5e 5 night here and d4
switch the move order this is what you
want to get in so some pawn structure
with some e 5 D for structure so just do
a five drop that pond and now I don't
see that there's going to be
compensation for the material you've
invested what are some things to look
for if you're going to be investing
material do you have a lead in
development you don't and I there's no
structural deficiencies I guess that's
another secondary thing to look into but
again the primary thing in most cases
out of the opening is if you're going to
be investing ponds any type of material
do you have a lead in development and
white doesn't there's no leading
development if anything I have a leading
development I'm able to get all my
pieces out so my suggestion is really
coming back to the this e 5 will just
meet the threat first on here 'if I've
night here and then this or there's even
I think Knight f3 Bishop c4 stuff but
eventually be five pawn on e5 grab some
space follow up with d4 in a short order
within the next two three moves but
again Knight f3 Bishop c4 or some other
ID
again you don't have compensation at
least I'm not seeing it for having given
up the material having given up these
ponds there's structural defects as well
that are some concern to white these
comes being split and well three ponds
actually there's three isolated ponds so
not really the direction to go in v5
consider that very early on okay